hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John Humphrey an army of the beats
we're gonna watch today what is this
long video called this is a dinner-party
swinglish BTS bangtan dinner party
awesome this is a topper war video
request from a patron who's been a
patron for a while named Laura Moore
thanks Laura for sending this over at
our patreon page we do weekly q and A's
and TV show reaction stream alongs and
homeboy here covers music videos Monty
really one of those are BTS or some type
of kpop so if you want some uncut music
vid reactions go over to our patreon
page today let's check this out
[Music]
[Music]
they get excited about food the way I
get excited I would love to have a real
dinner party with
[Laughter]
whoa it's here already they're so human
I always take a long time to get to them
actually this is how they say grace it's
like when they shoot an explosion or
drinks out
he's the youngest
[Music]
I've been there
it's alright cover it anytime with
banked animals every little detail of us
a whole conversation this is it really
is like your actual him and I both know
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean you know when you're like seven
people actually pretty fast and I
remember like the littlest details from
how was the first time I saw sweet
potato
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway we got to the rooms played arcade
I hope we get to do something like this
[Applause]
very impressive so how they're so
fascinated by things like history but
it's gonna get ugly I think it was not
to try more food
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's forward that's fashion
I love i weirdly see all the things that
make them successful in this there's my
four details wait up for 55 minutes we
have comment
Lavar em everything's like hey it's
different it's cool it's cool the man
has a he's gonna start a rhythm this is
a show so weird is different all around
I know he's just teasing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah now you just live in the moment take
things known by movin now record sales
are going to go down guys videos come
out I have not
I feel reactions man there was got to be
bigger I was gonna inject more
production values bigger expressions and
more nuance they did spend less time
answering that question mr. questions
too fast he's also like the tallest
right
[Laughter]
four days
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I imagine anything any one of them wants
to probably see
[Music]
I'm still young he'll develop some
self-awareness kid it's a real talent
you might get somewhere in love now I'm
back when are they needed to come back
no I think in in kpop that's just when
you come back with the new single to
announce from I don't think it's the
same
[Music]
somebody explain that to me
but everyone's saying it's him
considering unbeliever I hope everyone
says money boy thanks guys make eye
contact with Emily come on guys just
seems like such an odd man out safe
answer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
imagine toner ability is important this
is hard for them to get ahold of each
other
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay let's start making how much a
homophobic slur the day they would never
never have they would don't even don't
even clear David words make a sarcastic
comment Greg I'm sorry don't suck that
out in the universe
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
send it in a group or roll
my motto is you're not good enough so
keep trying
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we'll never be as great as you
[Music]
I'm afraid
[Music]
[Laughter]
makes sense can in turn with your body
it's like a really forced meditation
[Music]
everyone has a method same amenity smoke
masked snort
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
get over in the corner
[Laughter]
[Music]
one day
working the clock gating okay
[Music]
[Music]
it's amazing
[Music]
well you you definitely don't have any
independence you guys give me some more
no no we are filming right now oh he's
good [ __ ] to look good and one year I
got straight A's actions god I found and
you wonder why I can't have you in here
when were recording those notes ma'am
I'll learn the music theory said the guy
who [ __ ]
oh come on we came this far give
yourself a score
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we just have to listen you guys like do
lotteries
Oh
[Music]
this one our subscribers - no you mean
nothing it's all John and Greg you've
done nothing help I don't get this
attitude they have we could do this with
no views I'm kidding especially
whoever's watching that's like
forgetting that there's a camera so fast
say what you're talking to me is
fascinating this been a while since
we've done a reaction like a full-out
[Music]
[Music]
money [ __ ] the most stone-faced guy
[Laughter]
is master troll
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
that's right that's right you
Schindler's List crying out of joy in a
nap
they say tears release more endorphins
than any medication to help you feel
happy
my team it's Rob sexting I'm generally
quite depressed reviews oh dude it
really works like once a year yeah
crying video I'm very in touch with my
emotions I think you should have a cry
right now at the end of this [ __ ]
[Music]
more dinners together alright just pulls
out of line and coke on his hand hey man
that's how you secret it's not hunger
for the rap game really it's just a lot
of coke I know buddy
ate and now you're hungry again no we
wants to watch the dinner Melora sent
this over she did explain what this was
and I totally forgot that she explained
it until 15 minutes in haha man I wish
she told of what she totally did tell me
it's just that happened bitter cuz that
was like when are they gonna cut away
some footage of their dancing yeah this
is great this is like the best
combination of an interview and a
mukbang I'll roll into one yeah I
thought this was grating just them
actually hanging out chitchatting with
each other really getting to see what
they're like if they're just kickin it
you know oh yeah you get a sense for the
chemistry and the family brotherly vibe
yeah well especially early on in the
conversation where they were talking
about like just the little list of
things the coatings are like breaking
down the my new shove each other's
fashions and different personalities but
even like that first 20 minutes is just
them talking about like food and stuff I
was noticing that level of mindset I've
listened to and read about
like oh they just they just possess it
and almost every bit of the way they
talk you know it's not something they
just channel when they go into work mode
even if they're kicking back and being
loose the idea of how detail-oriented
they are but also the level of interest
and just pure fascination they have with
so many things even the little list of
things no phrase I heard forever ago is
turn frustration into fascination and
also don't get through the day get from
the day and you could just see that from
how they remember the tiniest things in
the way they interact and talk with each
other the support level of just so much
of clapping going on for everything they
just celebrates so much like the
constant progress and a constant way to
uplift each other that idea over there
talking about how they all influence one
another is apparent obvious and super
present throughout this whole video this
whole video you can see it
oh yeah they totally have that familial
supportive tight unit even as they're
raiding their own existences and like
trying to kind of buck each other up if
they're rating themselves too low or
whatever and the way they're also being
very vulnerable throughout all this
while it is fun and you know funny a lot
of the time you also have some actual
heartfelt like I love how philosophical
this got while also being you know a
funny interview over food yeah you know
because especially yet getting into
their mottos and hearing about the
feelings they would be having and their
different temperaments and how you know
it's like gin he's like okay well I
always want to bring up the move I don't
like when things get gloomy and seeing
what roles they all fall into in a
different way like beyond the hot band
you know like oh here's the edgy one
it's like you really do see how they
form a support unit for each other in an
artistic environment for each other
because it's like they all can do shades
of the say it's like we were joking
about like I'm pretty sure anything you
try to do you'll probably do well yeah
and even though there is that confidence
and stuff it is fascinating to kind of
see what people in their position on top
of the world still aspire to or feel
like they're not hitting so well there
are certain times where things got a
little more
and then I was even expecting which was
nice which was refreshing especially
when they were talking about some of the
more difficult emotions and whatnot in
the ways in which they deal with them
there was like a whole question about
that
and it seemed like a good dinner
conversation you know it was like the
perfect amount of light fun and adorable
and stuff like all the things that make
people I imagine just endeared towards
the group but also some things that yeah
you can just kind of take and learn from
and apply to your own creative process
in your own creative community sure I
would imagine especially when they were
all going around talking about their fan
base mm-hmm it seemed it was so
detail-oriented and how they broke it
down how they feel towards their fans
and the importance of them and it
sounded the furthest thing from shallow
it seemed so sincere because so many
times you hear people just casually say
it's because of the fans because of you
guys it sometimes it sounds like a thing
that you're supposed to say especially
on YouTube yeah you know say anything
like what this show happened and you
know back in our earlier the six-year
fans and stuff especially when our M was
talking about how they have all these
you know anxieties or worries before
they go out there but then they kind of
morph into something else when they hear
that energy the emotion that crowd gives
them when they're coming out to those
screams on stage essentially it's like
oh this is what it's all about right
here you know it's like some people and
especially who pursue music now a lot of
that really relies heavily on you nerds
putting up videos on YouTube or Spotify
or something again in the views and
clicks and downloads there but that
connection with the crowd is something I
imagine is rather unique and the
entertainment history for musicians
especially your singers artists like
these guys when you're would that crowd
I can't imagine there's anything that
that beats that feeling what yeah the
music video can do it no view can't
couldn't beat that literally a crowd of
a thousand I'm sure beats 20 million
views you know what I mean and I love
the way he summed that up as this
feeling of sort of being outside of
yourself it's after standing next to
your own spirit and away and and and
that's the other thing too is I love the
kind of poetic flourishes the
come with a lot of the stuff they
discuss you pointed him out like
jungkook in the corner man like yeah
especially being the youngest and and
like what we learned about him from the
last video it's fascinating to watch as
he interacts from everybody what's up
dude
just loves BTS there are certain moments
where I I don't know if he intended it
or not but I feel like he could be
slightly you know sneak attack with the
humor
weirdly he's the one I click with the
most because they're just reminding me
one of being a younger brother as a six
year age gap between my brother and I
and sometimes I'd be around him and his
friends were all older than me
you kind of get talked to or spoken to
when you're gonna get teased yeah yeah
there's a bit of that like he's
obviously shy and I don't think they
bully him no no but he is automatically
set up to be the one who's gonna get
teased because automatic thing of you're
the youngest one so we might easier yeah
and it is a very brotherly dynamic so I
feel like it kind of lends himself to
being a little bit on the shire more
quiet side especially in the discussion
format like this but when he speaks up
he usually makes it count it's like he
doesn't talk a lot yeah yeah video but
yeah he's always like I got a second
he's lost in thought sugar is probably
my favorite just because of how
mysterious he is he's the polar opposite
corner he's like that dude who doesn't
realize he's super sexy but that's part
of what makes him so sexy yeah yeah yeah
way up in a sweater you know and it's so
much about the expression of his art he
doesn't seem stuff like self-involved to
the degree of like look how great I am
none of them do everyone's is very
honest and willing to just be like
actually I have a different take on on
what this very specific thing is that
we're talking about whether it be
happiness models own life how to deal
with feeling like they're in a slump the
different ways they deal with it some of
them just take it head-on and some
people think it's better get your mind
off of things since I was like go out in
the car
yeah go out in the school I've heard
that I get it get back in touch your
body that's part of what sort of
meditation is is getting back in tune
with your body to put you back in the
present moment so you're not just
obsessed with the thoughts of lack of or
what
got a do or something like that just
helps you recenter yourself and I can't
imagine the amount of pressure these
guys are under I feel like it might be
easier for them to hyper-focus and it
would be to get their mind off what they
got to do it's the amount they do in a
day
or all day every day and for so many
years and even hearing about how they
were used to divide the rooms of it's
like having those things to think about
when you're living like all together
I imagine that yeah this has come with a
lot of time and experience and trial and
error and what fascinated me more than
you know the specifics of this video is
just I wonder how the culture is
different because this is of all like
the music interviews I've ever seen
this is like the most kind of
well-rounded and supportive and
vulnerable while being also fun and I
you know it's it's the format of this
show but there's just something about
them all together where there's like a
real supportive vulnerability they
talked about even like crying and the
different ways in which that can be like
a happy thing or a useful thing and
these are things I'm just not as used to
hearing here so I wonder yeah what you
know if that's also kind of baked into
the culture there I see it and a lot of
acting circles I don't really know music
circles all that well considering the
amount of artistic collaboration they do
and how far they've gone it doesn't
surprise me at all that they would be as
vulnerable as they are because they're
still evidently layers of them that get
uncomfortable to be expressive about
certain emotional things but they do it
anyway and they'll even lead with or
make fun of each other about it and
having that ability to tease each
other's I think very important to ya
know I think a lot of the time if you
can't take a joke if the person or
people you're working with if you can't
just take a little bit of being teased
of course there's a line and then you
know at the same time though there's
also the ego that just wants to be taken
so seriously and it's hard to
collaborate I don't feel like that would
lend itself to having a bit of a loose
enough dynamic to create if you if you
can't if you take yourself that
seriously where you can't tease one
another oh yeah and that also really
shows here and also RM and tuff for such
a long time but I think the last thing I
point out is like RM as a leader that's
even at display here when they're when
they're talking you know he doesn't try
to steal the spotlight he's a real
yeah he's empowering he knows his
position but even on the great scale of
what he was talking about with the point
system he can't get myself to hire - I
read a book called 21 laws of leadership
and the first law is called law of the
lid and that basically means the people
that are following you as a leader if
you're at a level eight the highest you
could bring them as to like a level
seven and the thing is he's so good at
empowering that there's a part of me
that feels like he kind of breaks the
mold on that law a little bit he doesn't
toot his horn too high he keeps it at
such a reasonable level and he's
constantly empowering left and right and
he doesn't always try to tie it back
into himself and he's part of an
ensemble to where he is in the same
position versus you know a true position
above them you know true and I think the
rest of his teammates are good at
empowering RM and empowering each other
all around as well and no credit can be
a big deal for any type of team or
ensemble or whatever unit but it's
always best when the team knows how to
compliment or credit each other properly
it's a one-person having to do it all so
I think it's great yeah John get your
act together in a [ __ ] you know I'll do
better
I'll watch more BTS videos learn all
their names from the real names not
their rap names too much improv cut it
out and trim it down you'll get there
one day I'm ahead of a hundred I'm like
a hundred I'm a six now I'm negative
four that's more like it
that's what I want to hear raise
yourself to hi John there's nowhere else
to go I'm just gonna stay a solid zero
from all good that'll always get you
pursuing to try to add some more points
I'm always in the room always have all
of it to improve upon it guys thank you
for watching along with us thanks for
sticking around for our just as long
discussion mmm you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
Bell check us out on patreon where
homeboy does music video reactions and
if you pledge you could send suggestions
you know most likely do it go over there
today and Laura thank you so much for
what
in this my dear it's been great having
you engage with us so much at our
patreon page as of late spread the word
about the reject nation throughout West
Virginia all right I looked up your name
essentially comes been down to the
embodiment of victory and strength just
like I am with my vocabulary
so with that victory and strength
quality of yours spread the reject
nation around West Virginia keep being
the strong general in the BTS army yeah
and let the East Coast know conquer the
East Coast of America about BTS land I
like BTS you're not in a k-pop watch
these American guys who sometimes watch
BTS and I guarantee you the perfect
gateway you are just you know killing
two birds with one stone you know as
many birds as you can on stones take a
gun kill a bird with a stone stone
launcher